welcome it is via playing p.m. that's a
new onand okay oh no that's do the
Benoni experimented a little bit
recently with hands simply declining it
jack yeah this is supposed to be good
for whites but hmm I would like to know
it better snide you two already not
completely sure not sure about the move
order
we could have gone night h5 them okay
i'm going to make sure I've got a square
and not sure about 94 immediately he has
98 it's not quite clear that it helps me
so much or if 493 is probably right just
stay solid there night c4 maybe I should
have gone right see for how to see we
should f8 or something if he has to go
bishop I've ate something is entirely
wrong so let's do it yeah that looks
that looks weird
yeah but ultimately where are you going
with this probably to see ADA if I go
like g4 yeah I mean you cannot play 97
in the first place g4s trapping the
bishop ok ok now it's not trapped but
but what an awkward position so let's
seem wonder if I can do something
drastic already
night a form and probably p can probably
take you five doesn't look great but may
be possible
okay let's do this I'm not sure about
this here because I probably have more
than one good continuation and ideas
this
yeah see six and A six is both very
seriously week now yeah thinking about
it looks you want and then B form but
also love to play f3 you for some time
but it's not easy to do night on d6 in
itself isn't doing that much looks nice
but it doesn't do that much ok he's
returning so before Teague's not be five
that's very messy but probably also good
let's do it let's do it I'm already
behind on the clock this is this is so
typical I they play a really really
terrible opening and both trying to
completely review it you spend too much
time it happens to me quite often it's
just sometimes better to play something
good not the best thing just something
good and be be somewhat quick about it
then really try to completely refute
them that play here I can take on before
stupid me again I get nervous with no
time for a little time yeah of course
simple tactic does work it does work now
I mean okay problem maybe I can still
play this takes Bishop c3 so that's some
kind of pin that I can use queen bee
three or something that's still possible
maybe
should c 3 queen bee three maybe i can
pin them of course it's so entirely
unnecessary ok I've got night a 611 way
to do it 95 or okay three okay let's do
this didn't plan any of that I just
blundered this stuff maybe
maybe 95 is even play Lenore this okay
yeah so is that this look and two nights
against Queen and pawns talk about a
weird material balance your imbalance
rather check
yeah not easy here we should back to g3
and then open it 76 something like that
tough time warning I cannot click
unbelievable i cannot play something
that detects the pond either the fish up
there this one this one maybe even
though it looks entirely unnatural
now 92 or something I don't get it here
what a mess we should be fun having this
this this 92 what am I playing against
instance night f1 also this one Queen f5
is an idea now and queens you form
check yeah just just Trix Trix Trix okay
he's currently check check check check
black for fits on time okay well Jim
that that's really not good young I mean
this is this is just winning this
position it's not really just better or
anything the position is so awful I
should just win it but didn't manage
simply didn't manage it should be true
maybe that's too lame the engine once
once Knight b6 air Queen B 6 but I
didn't really see I mean I saw I saw the
move but couldn't really like it just go
back here guide you can't just go back
and win that okay yeah and that's it
just win the pawn yeah I mean this is
just not good for him but it's not
winning if I can win that is six point I
really should and then this this is not
this is not that clear this is really
not that clear and this is maybe yeah
who the angel actually likes a move but
wants to go queen bee three now yeah
this is engine gives equal funny but not
with this with through a three
yeah I considered that but I thought
that why not this because of 95 ok hmm
now that's possible
yeah black keeps the peace just keeps
the peace did I make a mistake here
roocase six is better check the engine
assesses this is roughly equal it's it's
just a total total mess with no time on
the clock or now Knight e5 was
straightaway winning okay threatens
naija form with meat and nida three
check something like this is a pretty
very strong check checkmate and again 95
would have one and I he is also winning
it seems but this 100 now with Roxy five
now night ec5 was the only move it seems
according to the engine this 95 so draw
it seems check Wow
yeah that uses ship t6 is supposed to be
a draw check check check check Bishop a
3m has to be played I'm king of one
ideas this yeah it seems that I'm
winning that Bishop because black is so
and tied together this is what the
engine is giving check and says draw
yeah probably a guy will you set pong
what a wiki game okay thanks for
watching